la pyramide du grand louvre est ouverte
au public comme toutes les nouveautés
elle déclenche toutes sortes
d'appréciation de la part de ce public
dominique bayo a promené son micro pour
recueillir des réactions à chaud 3
millions de visiteurs par an jusqu'à
présent
mais le louvre devrait voir ses adeptes
augmenter considérablement
et tout cela grâce à une entrée
supplémentaire une entrée certes très
monumental dès aujourd'hui la queue du
public était impressionnante
la polémique semblait bien lointaine et
tous les présents se déclaraient
pyramidaux fils oui ça me plaît vraiment
s'il ya des choses que je considère
comme une discutable
d'autres réalisations modernes pas celle
là qu'est-ce que vous êtes de n'y voir
exactement l'architecturé intérieure
vous croyez que ça va être très la
librairie et la librairie
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'elle a voir je
suis libraire il paraît qu'il est assez
extraordinaire qu'il a movie fantastique
qui était très cher les premiers
visiteurs furent obligés de subir une
fouille méthodique présence
présidentielle oblige un président qui
semblait ravie du succès populaire et
qui prolongera sa visite pour un petit
bain de foule à signaler pour les
économes que pendant cinq jours l'entrée
sera gratuite
le musée va également ouvrir pour des
nocturnes mais il serait dommage de ne
pas profiter de l'incontestable réussite
lumineuse que constitue la pyramide
c'est joli extérieur c'est joli
d'intérieur enfin c'est super ça va te
donner envie de venir au louvre
énormément